[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator tv
and broadcast on thursday october 14th
i'm katie balls the spectator's deputy
political editor
on this week's show
how did the government mishandle covert
fraser nelson and james forsyth will
join us to discuss
a new report says boris and his team
failed to challenge scientific guidance
could this be the beginning of an
american style distrust or authority
douglas murray will be on the show
fewer and fewer people in developed
countries are choosing to have children
with an increasing number blaming
climate dread a fear the world won't be
safe to start a family in
are they wrong we'll speak to the
journalist maddy cairns and the
researcher ray
philosophy professor kathleen stock has
been handed by students and activists
because of her views on gender do
academics still have freedom of speech
matthew goodwin the writer and kent
university professor says no and he'll
be on with robert ford from the
university of manchester who takes a
slightly different view
and finally the recently leaked pandora
papers showed the finances of the rich
and famous among them one of vladimir
putin's alleged mistresses who is
supposed to have had a child with him
why is the russian leader so secretive
about his private life i'll be joined by
owen matthews to try and answer that
question
before we get going if you enjoy
spectator tv you should subscribe to our
youtube channel just click the red
subscribe button at the bottom of this
video and tap the bell icon to make sure
you never miss an episode again
and why not also subscribe to the
spectator magazine while you're at it
you can get 12 weeks of the magazine and
a free 20 amazon voucher for just 12
pounds to take up the deal just go to
www
dot spectator dot code uk forward slash
tb offer
first up
two conservative led committees have
released a report on the government's
covert response they say the government
relied too heavily on scientists and it
was too late in locking down the country
who was in the firing line and has the
report missed something
i'm joined now by fraser nelson and
james forsythe
fraser let's start with you what did you
make of the report
i was struck by what it didn't say i
mean the biggest question of the last 18
months is whether lockdowns worked or
not at the beginning nobody had the
faintest idea it's never been used
before in pandemic control now lockdowns
have been implemented by countries right
around the world we've got so many
studies right now we've got something
like two and a half thousand studies
coming out every week into covert
lockdown and the various effects so we
know there's now a wealth of data that
we can look at and the government so the
parliamentary committee didn't really
look at this data now what jumps out to
me is the
behavior of people before lockdown the
question the modeling assumed that
unless the government's told people to
go and stay at home they wouldn't that
life would continue as before in fact we
now know because right now everybody
carries around a mobile phone with them
and google can track people going to
work people going to the park people
going to the shops so the google
mobility data is incredibly rich
incredibly detailed and available for
cities and countries around the world
now that data shows us that by the time
the lockdown procedures were implemented
there were something like 60
reduction in the number of people going
to work it didn't really get much more
of a reduction after that so people had
already seen what was happening and
changed their behavior accordingly now
the international monetary fund has done
a study of similar surveys right around
the world and it's found that for
democracies for advanced economies which
are information rich where people can
follow the news on their smartphones and
every time the infection levels were
going up people were slightly more
inclined to stay at home and reduce
their mobility so by using kind of
common sense by listening to the advice
not the instructions but the advice of
government
you were able to come to a common sense
solution over here and we didn't do that
over here of course we went for lockdown
we went we set the police after people
walking their dogs people going for
drinks in the park together but sweden
was the only country that didn't use the
police they went for a kind of voluntary
response and that worked sweden twice
forced back coveted peaks for people
staying at home voluntarily now the data
suggests that britain could have done
that too we didn't necessarily need to
adopt the wuhan model and the rather
authoritarian
regime that we ended up living under
lockdown to get the desired effects so
this is the most intriguing question now
that we've got the data now that we can
see how people in advanced democracies
respond to news of a worsening pandemic
if they do stay at home if they do
follow advice do you really need to use
lockdown do you really need to get the
police involved and do you really need
to impose the collateral damage the
lockdowns always entail to me this is
the single most interesting question
about covid's and it's a question which
i'm afraid to say the select committee
didn't get around to looking at let
alone answering
james when it comes to fraser's points
is there any thinking going on in
government at least on the answers to
those questions or is it really a case
of hopefully the worst the pandemic is
over let's not think or talk about it
i think if you look at the government's
uh plan for the winter a lot of it does
rely on the kind of things that fraser
was talking about you know just simply
warning people that the situation is bad
might lead to sufficient changes in
behavior to kind of bring the r8 back
down again so i i think the government
is moving away from the kind of
sledgehammer approach of lockdowns
to to kind of uh to kind of subtler more
gradative policies which is obviously
easier to do now
that uh such a high proportion of the
population have been vaccinated against
covet i think one of the other things i
was struck by the report was it talks
about the lack of
data that the government had to assess
the situation which is true but i'm
still struck even now by the poor
quality of the data coming out i mean i
think it's remarkable but we don't have
a time since even 18 months into the
pandemic of how many people are actually
dying each day because uh deaths are not
uh there's often quite a lag especially
at the weekends
in when deaths are reported or not and i
mean this is a problem which is when you
are trying to make policy and the date
which is uh and the data is not up to
date i mean i think that is an issue uh
i don't think that will be a particular
issue because according to the
spectators um philip thomas model at the
moment you know the r8 has now gone back
above one and so i think that you know
that and the relatively slow pace of the
booster program i i i think there will
be a few more debates about what kind of
interventions are needed in the coming
weeks fraser when it comes to
who emerges you know the worst or the
best from the report it really does feel
as though there's enough blame to go
around public health england scientists
ministers none come out particularly
well there's a little praise from matt
hancock on his testing target was there
anyone who struck out to you reading
that report as deserving of praise
i'm afraid to say not really but that's
the general rule with covets i don't
think there's anybody in the whole world
who handles code particularly well the
only question is how it caught everybody
by surprise everybody made huge mistakes
that were perhaps inevitable given how
little information we had and even now
it's way too early to say who has been a
success and coveted who hasn't because
we haven't seen the effects of lockdown
yet we still haven't seen the long-term
effects on them closing the schools on
healthcare we still don't know how this
is going to end israel isn't going to
hit some kind of herd immunity through
vaccination that means curb won't come
back in the winter or is the recent
revival in the covered numbers um senior
spectator data hub we're now looking at
38 000 cases a day up from 34 000 that's
going in the wrong direction is that an
indication that we're about to hit yet
another wave in the winter now the
philip thomas model suggests not but who
knows one thing you know about covert is
that it takes everybody by surprise
so i think you know maybe in four or
five years time we might get a report
that could say in a meaningful way who
did well and who did badly the truth is
everybody still now to a very large
extent is just taking a leap in the dark
and it'll be some time before we find
out who if anybody has landed in
daylight
james one of the things i was struck by
is almost how little commotion at the
report has caused if you look in
government in number 10
you would think in a way if you walked
away a report was just so damning talks
about the worst public health crisis in
history for the uk
could at least lead to talker's
resignations but there's nothing like
that do you think um when it comes to
you know
where there will be consequences is
there concerning 10 dining street over
the eventual
inquiry is that a cause of concern or
not so much
i mean the public inquiry where you see
people giving evidence almost certainly
under oath that that will attract a lot
of attention but i suspect in terms of
the politics the this inquiry is not
going to report until after the next
election and so in some ways there is
some distance i also think one of the
reasons why um
you alluded to this in in a piece you
wrote this week katie one of the reasons
why the report didn't cause that much
commotion is what it said essentially
reflected the kind of current
westminster consensus which was the uk
should have locked down um
earlier than it did uh it should have
been more aware that uh the plan should
have been for um uh a kind of star virus
rather than purely planning for an
influenza pandemic
but the government did get uh vaccine
procurement uh in the first place right
that it was right to order all these
doses in advance before the efficacy of
these vaccines
had been proved so i i think the report
was uh and i think it's worth noting
that the these two select committees
came to a unanimous report because it it
essentially reflects the current
consensus in thinking about how this uh
virus has been handled now fraser
looking ahead uh when it comes to what
boris johnson and his ministers are
concerned about in the coming months
we've heard about the effing crisis
energy fuel and food
where's covert on this is it you know
top five concern or does boris johnson
feel as though he has bigger fish to fry
well rightly or wrongly covered really
has dropped out of that top five i've
been struck how long i can go now
without hearing covert mentioned by the
government ministers and other
politicians that i speak to is there is
as a big what if like what if there is a
covert plus flu combination this winter
it's not as even as if covert has gone
away i mean right now there are still
thousands of people in hospital with
covet but we are now getting to the
stage where we're like we now regard it
as a background noise a background
disease it's up there it's a killer in
the same way as influenza we're getting
used to it in a way now of course that
might change we might get a new variant
as happened this time last year all of
these things are possible but right now
i think the government is really getting
quite worried about the as you call it
kt the effing crisis the energy fuel and
food boris johnson was a bit rash in
claiming ownership of this crisis making
out in last week's tory conference this
was part of a cunning plan of his to put
um wages up but having laid claim to it
he is going to have to own it if this
crisis doesn't go away and if this
crisis leads to shortages right up until
christmas with perhaps more serious side
effects i don't think anybody again this
is a worldwide crisis it's not just
britain you can look at what's happening
in america right now and it's very
similar stories but because of the way
boris johnson's handled it it's kind of
on him now in a way it wouldn't have
been and he decided to take a different
line at tory party conference so that's
why i think the shortages rather than
covet will be the government's number
one sort of ghost of christmas future
panic right now and james just finally
another problem the government faces on
the northern ireland protocol there have
been efforts this week uh david frost
gave a speech and the european
commission have been setting out
potential measures to ease some of the
problems with the current checks and but
yet dominic cummings has popped up as he
has a tendency to do and made things a
little bit more difficult for the
government what's going on there
oh well dominic has sent a kind of
series of tweets suggesting that uh the
uk government's plan although um donald
cummings says not boris johnson not uh
he doesn't excuse boris johnson because
johnson thought this plan was wrong but
he says boris johnson didn't know what
he'd signed uh and so kind of wasn't in
on this was to
essentially to uh to try and kind of
get get the deal done including the
normal island protocol and then
basically once you sign the deal try and
change the protocol try and fix it
afterwards and this has led to lots of
accusations of bad faith you've had uh
the irish deputy prime minister leo
veradka who will obviously become the
tishok again under their coalition
agreement to
suggest that you know any country about
to sign a free trade deal with britain
should be very wary because this is not
necessarily a government that sticks to
its word i think in terms of what
cescovich has outlined there is enough
there for there to be a negotiation
between the uk and the eu
i think the question then becomes
whether there is enough trust and trust
is not a commodity and high supply when
it comes to um there's a supply source
of trust you might say when it comes to
uk eu relations uh if there's enough
trust to set this thing up on on a more
sustainable
durable footing
i mean there's going to be a particular
row about the role of the ecj
i think there are ways around that you
know you could look at for example
the way that the swiss um
deal with the eu handles the ecj or even
the way that the uk the broader uk eu
um free trade agreement handles the ecj
question so i think there are ways
around this but i think that um
but i think we are we are in for uh not
immediately but we will be in for over
the coming months some more brexit drama
about this uh some more uh bad temper
negotiations although i did think it was
interesting that david frost's speech
while sweeping in terms of what it
wanted in terms of change the protocol
was um
by the standards of this government
relatively restrained in its language
thanks james thanks fraser
if the scientists got a lot wrong are
you in danger of seeing what's happened
in america a widespread mistrust of
institutions like the police the
intelligence services and of government
more generally
douglas murray makes the case in his
column this week and joins me now
douglas thanks for coming on um when it
comes to the report ultimately the
government have been accused of doing
the wrong thing by listening to experts
but isn't that what we're supposed to be
doing
uh well yes i mean obviously there's
been an extraordinary 18 months in which
all of us in the public have allowed
unimaginable previously unimaginable
infringements on our freedom limitations
on our freedom
all at the advice of experts the
government in britain as in countries
around the world has repeatedly and
routinely said we're just listening uh
to the experts and so whenever uh those
experts have a knock against their
expertise as it were i should say in the
column you know
a lot of other things happen
uh when as this week with the mps report
you you see the things again that we've
seen so many times in the last 18 months
of the scientific advice getting it
wrong
of predictions extrapolations
being wildly wrong
it's not enough just to park that and
think well that's a mistake this
this has a follow-on effect a set of
follow-on effects
that all of us are going to feel and i
mentioned in passing in the column of
course i feel it myself
i i tend to defer
as i think people ought to
to experts in areas that i'm not expert
in
um and
i say if i go to a hospital when i break
a bone i don't look up online to see
home remedies for brome for bone
breakage
and it's the same with pandemics it's
the same loss things at the moment that
actually that deference to expertise is
shown
to be much more questionable than we
might like a whole set of other doubts
start to creep in and that's really what
the column's about yes and you say in
your column there actually one of the
things that concerns you is if you look
to the us we could end up going in a
similar way now you spend a lot of time
in the united states and you're speaking
now from there
so what exactly do you mean by that what
do you see
well there's something that is
almost completely unremarked upon very
little understood about america that i
think is absolutely astonishing it's
happened in the last few years and it's
this
the um
the american right in particular
um has become something which is
unrecognizable from even five years ago
in one sense in particular which is its
wild distrust of any and every
institution uh you know a conservatism
used to be um intrinsically caught up
with the idea of veneration of
institutions and as i say even five
years ago the american right
you could predict that for instance they
would be
very very reverent towards the military
they would
revere the intelligence agencies cia fbi
nsa and and so on uh they had uh trust
in other institutions including the law
uh the legal system and much more
and we're now at a position in the
states where for reasons which are
fascinating and probably
too lengthy to get into today
that has completely changed
so that the american right uh now not
just distrusts but actually derides uh
the military chiefs i mean they they
still respect the the the soldiery they
still respect uh the men and women
in uh uniform but the top brass you know
the the chairman of joint chiefs of
staff routinely ridiculed
on the evening news programs uh on uh
right wing news and uh conservative
columnists lampoon these people they
mock them uh it's the same
with the intelligence agencies the nsa
the cia
these are
now uh institutions which the american
right has profound doubt about um
believes very often that there are
conspiracies going on uh involving them
uh
other examples uh the inland revenue uh
the internal revenue service um other
other wings of government and then you
get the final one of course which is
wild distrust
in the actual
act of voting and the way in which votes
are added up now as i say in the column
i mean i think people should see this as
a warning because the american right has
not got to this position from nowhere
it's got there among other things
because of the extraordinary
politicization of its intelligence
services and the military top brass
don't forget the general milly
chairman joint chiefs of staff was
talking about and defending the teaching
of critical race theory at west point
whilst afghanistan fell apart
the former head of the nsa and the cia
mike hayden
was in the summer tweeting that trump
voters are the same as the taliban
we've seen uh investigations uh we've
seen uh croc uh conspiracies pouring out
from previously respected entities and
of course then we have the um incredibly
uh toxic issue of the judiciary and the
actual act of counting votes and i say
this is a warning should be seen as a
warning by everybody outside america you
know institutions don't just have and
experts don't just have um respect
because respect is always going to be
offered to them they have respect re
acquire respect and retain respect
by respecting the public in turn by
being able to level with the public when
they've got things wrong
by a certain degree of transparency not
a complete transparency but a certain
degree of transparency muck this up
politicize it
and you end up in this position as i say
where conservative people in america
overwhelmingly
distrust all of the institutions that
only a few years ago we would have
called conservative in some way
and as you say douglas a lot of this
criticism in america comes from the
right so when you're looking to the uk
we've obviously touched on the official
scientific advice um new doubts now
about public health england about
scientific advisors and there any other
institutions which you think
are ones where potentially carry this
risk um if you look ahead to a few years
time i mean the bbc is clearly one where
the government too lands blows against
it so what institutions do you think are
particularly vulnerable to this in the
uk
yes i think by the way the one that you
missed from that list but of course you
and i know it's very interesting is
government
um it it almost goes without saying that
people distrust government
or at least expect government uh
not to be entirely level with them on
certain things i mean obviously people
who don't vote for a particular
government are going to be more
suspicious but even people who do vote
for instance for the conservative
government in britain don't expect it
itself and boris johnson at the head of
it to be the crucible of all truth and
honesty you know we've built in a
certain amount of suspicion about
politicians
it's the expertise behind that
as you say
principally the one i think is striking
is is the
looming if not already existing loss of
respect for the scientific advisors and
for the idea of listening to the science
which has been one of the things we've
been told about so much over the last 18
months but you're right there are many
other institutions that come in behind
us bbc is a very good one i think
they've actually been efforts clearly
there have been efforts in the last year
and more
to try to make sure the bbc doesn't go
the way that you could see it going of
of completely losing the trust of as it
were all sides in the political uh
spectrum and and i suppose in a way this
is this is a
um this is a call to to to shore up
those institutions that do still have
residual public trust
uh i mean everybody has their critiques
of an institution like the bbc uh i i i
among many others but
actually what you see if you if if you
see the scenario in america where for
instance i mean the left has uh just as
much distrust of institutions it's just
a you know
fortunately for them their guy got in
last year you know so they sort of
dampened it down the left in america
remember spent the previous four years
uh pretending uh that the 2016 election
had been stolen by a few russian bots so
so they actually don't believe in
election integrity particularly uh
either um but as i say when your guy's
in in power it's a bit easier to gloss
over some of this stuff because
temporarily broken or not the system
sort of worked for you
but all all of this is a warning that
that institutions experts and others
have to be incredibly wary about
politicizing themselves and and being
politicized
we have seen in britain extraordinary
cases of this in the past but i would
say by and large we remain in slightly
better health
we obviously in the 2000s had profound
questions and doubts for many people
about the security services and mi5 and
mi6 and particularly intelligence
failures
i would have said they've recovered from
that but there's a lesson in that as
well which is
not to enter the political arena if you
can and you should simply always if you
can resist it the problem in america has
been
non-political people or people at least
who should be above politics
immersing themselves in the day-to-day
fight of politics i gave you example of
mike hayden there
plenty of others i mean general milly
also i mentioned earlier
the importance of riding above that
is that if you don't
you exacerbate this sense of
politicization of the institutions which
itself leads to this incredible and i
have to justifiable mistrust and
distrust in the institutions
i think we've avoided that in britain
but it is a warning it should be a
warning
because
as i say in my column
to understand the situation that america
isn't in at the moment
you would have to imagine a conservative
movement in the uk
that
disliked and distrusted and mocked the
chiefs of the military
and all of this were justifiable reasons
as i say
which loathed mi5
hated mi6
um believed gchq routinely uh leaks
against journalists for instance uh
doesn't believe that the court system is
fair and also believes that we don't
have election integrity and you would
say in the british context if we listed
off those things well what's
conservative exactly about anybody who
thinks that that's a sort of
proto-revolutionary
set of views but that is the situation
in the u.s and i think it is a warning
to people in britain and elsewhere
thank you douglas it's a great pleasure
this week's cover story baby dumas looks
at why more and more people are choosing
not to start a family because of climate
dread they argue that bringing a child
into the world not only could make the
situation worse but there might not be
so much for the child to even enjoy by
the time they get to adulthood
are there fears unfounded the journalist
maddy kern says so in her cover piece
for this week's magazine she joins me
now along with brit ray the author
broadcaster and researcher from stanford
university
maddie britt thanks for coming on maddie
first can you explain your argument
yeah so it's a trend that we've seen uh
for some time now certainly in celebrity
culture people like megan and harry
spoke about limiting their family size
on the basis of climate change now we
have some polls that are showing that
this is more common than just a sort of
fringe phenomenon
it seems to be two main reasons why
people are are making this decision
the first is the argument that children
themselves contribute and worsen
the climate crisis and the second
argument is that it would not be fair to
children to bring them into a a planet
that is in such bad condition
brit you've researched the impact of
climate change and climate change
warnings on mental health what what have
you found
the climate crisis has an enormous
mental health burden that runs a large
spectrum so if we're talking about being
caught up in floods and fires or
hurricanes or heat waves for example we
have tons of evidence to show that that
can
result in creating mental health
disorders or exacerbating mental health
disorders whether we're talking about
post-traumatic stress disorder anxiety
depression
there's a huge impact on community that
can
disintegrate resilience um and
essentially cause sense of chronic uh
loneliness alienation things that
wear away at one's well-being however
there's also
the kind of indirect so to speak effects
that can come into effect one's mental
health even if you aren't anywhere near
the front lines of
such direct climate impacts and that is
when we get into talking about climate
anxiety eco anxiety the worrying and
concern that comes with understanding
the immense amount of um
havoc and danger that comes with warming
temperatures and so
the american psychological association
defines equal anxieties the chronic fear
of environmental doom
and that is essentially plain into what
maddie is talking about as to why young
people are feeling afraid to have kids
whether or not they are anywhere um
close to those kinds of climate
disasters but they're just thinking
about the world in which those kids
would have to grow up in
maddie do you share any of those
concerns
well i think it's certainly real i think
people are obviously very distressed and
making decisions out of that distress
my advice to to people not that they
asked for it would would be to sort of
live in the present which is of course
the
premise of all ancient wisdom is that we
shouldn't uh project ourselves too far
into the future for our own mental
health it's also the basis of cognitive
behavioral therapy
we're not supposed to catastrophize even
if those catastrophes are possible um
especially assuming the fears of of
other people so
of course the climate emergency is is
just that but it is affecting directly
affecting vulnerable people and key
global ecosystems it's not really going
to have as much of a day-to-day effect
on us and our gra and our children
that that's not a reason not to care but
it is a reason not to live in a
perpetual state of panic
brett do you agree with that do you
think there is a risk that we are in a
way
focusing too much on the catastrophizing
element and it is now holding young
people back in terms of making plans
i think that there's a false element of
safety there that was just articulated
as though there are only certain people
in the world that will be affected by
the climate crisis whereas privileged
relatively safe and secure citizens of
the
high income nations first world so to
speak um will not be touched by its
harms that already is showing to not be
true although of course it's a highly
disproportionate
um
system that we're living in and of
course predominantly people in low and
middle income countries and and
typically communities of color are being
hit hard and fast by the climate crisis
and others are
meaning maintaining a relative sense of
safety and ability to stay out of harm's
way
maddie you're in the united states you
know that there are heat waves and there
are
deadly wildfires and there are floods
and there are all kinds of issues that
are affecting communities and taking
lives
in in a country that would not be
considered um you know in that typical
basket that you were talking about about
uh those who will be harmed so this is
accelerating people are awake and aware
and seen that
given the scientific perspective that
the research tells us we need to
look at and act in accordance with when
we when we take that and then we match
it with something that's very key here
and that is what governments and leaders
are doing about it um then it brings in
the sense of hopelessness and despair or
at least extreme anxiety because we see
that those who are put in positions of
power who are meant to protect
population well-being and our health and
safety are not acting in accordance with
what the science is saying and that
creates this pervasive sense of moral
injury
and that can be uh really the propellant
for this kind of chronic sense of doom
that people are contending with right so
if our leaders were acting differently
if we saw that we were behaving
responsibly like adults paying attention
to the science and then changing our
systems and lifestyles well then maybe
we wouldn't have this anxiety in the way
that we're seeing it today but because
that isn't happening you have been the
key effects of a chronically worsening
planetary health state along with
the action which is basically no action
or delayed action and then you know it's
quite a normal and natural response that
people are feeling that's freaked out
about the world that they're moving
towards
maddie what do you say to that in your
pc talk about climate alarmism as one of
the things that's actually kind of
whipping up these concerns
sure so i want to clarify not for a
second suggesting that we live in a safe
world we never have lived in a safe
world we've lived in a world besieged
with famine and plague and natural
disaster and all sorts of human
suffering and misery i mean at the very
least each one of us can expect to
encounter during the course of our lives
uh profound difficulties and then of
course death
so i i'm not i'm not sort of saying that
it's all it's all rosy uh in this part
of the world i'm just saying a sense of
perspective is helpful i do live in the
united states and uh we have seen here
many natural disasters but i would again
sort of urge a sense of perspective so
you mentioned california i was in
california a couple years ago at a hotel
and half the hotel had actually been
affected by by a fire at some point
they'd evacuated nobody had been hurt
thank goodness um and life there was
carrying on more or less as normal and
the people weren't sort of running
around uh with with glum looking faces
they were they were getting on with it
with the business of living their lives
and that is all i am saying i'm saying
rather than live in a state of
anticipation of a of a future worst case
scenario it is better to get on with
living our lives of course engaging with
these these very serious issues doing
what we can i completely agree with you
that political change is what's
necessary here structural and political
change which is one of the reasons why i
think that the question of having
children is sort of irrelevant
population and demographics is not the
main cause of this
it is in fact failures on the political
level and in responding to the needs of
the world
and just finally very very briefly from
both of you and i wondered what is your
advice uh your one piece of advice to
you know someone watching this who
genuinely looks at the environment and
the planet and thinks that the climate
crisis means they shouldn't have a child
um rich you want to go first you've
written about this a little bit in your
book
yeah and and i
very much relate to anyone who feels
that way
four or five years ago i came into my
own
enormous dilemma of considering whether
or not i was going to have a child when
my partner and i
realized we really wanted to have a
child and then you know as a science
communicator i was looking at report
after climate report coming across my
desk and seeing that this this doesn't
really add up you know a safe future in
which i can
ensure that my child will
um be able to
you know move through the world in a at
a certain level of of security given
what everything is saying about like
migration crises water shortages
you know the potential for civil strife
that comes off the back of those kinds
of
um dwindling resources
et cetera um less climate disasters and
then um this desire of mine and it
created
a
a new type of eco anxiety within myself
that i needed to try and understand so i
went out and and started researching and
writing a book uh
to see
was i crazy for thinking this way or
were there other people out there that
this also resonated with and i
discovered that it was a growing
phenomenon at the time and by speaking
of any climate scientists and
psychologists and psychiatrists and
spiritual leaders and and all kinds of
different folks i i collected
perspectives that helped um
bring in a more nuanced discussion
around what it means to have a child in
in a climate changing world even one
that's becoming much more dangerous and
and less secure so uh you know four
years later i do have a one month old
and that is
something that i came to on my own for a
variety of reasons not just
because of what i've learned along this
journey but largely also because of
thinking very seriously about what it
means to put a kid into a climate
changed future and how parenting needs
to change and adjust for this reality
and you know that's my decision and i
would never advocate that others should
get over their fears and then go have a
child if that's what they really want i
think that they need to
take it seriously um consider all
aspects that are important to them and
know that there's no right decision in
this right there's huge pros and cons to
both there's lots of great reasons to
not have children and remain child free
and there's lots of great reasons to
have children um it's very complex and
complicated but i would just encourage
um those of us thinking about this
seriously to not shame others
for their uh struggles with this
question it's it's very painful it's
very emotional it's very real people are
thinking very hard about what the right
thing to do is and um you know
eventually have to make a decision that
they're able to live with so but yeah
that's that's my little story that i can
share that if you are feeling hopeless
about it at some point your perspective
might change um as it did for me
maddie what's your advice
um i would say you know there's more to
life than avoiding suffering of course
suffering is part of life but you may
also encounter
hope friendship meaning
love all these other things that make
life worthwhile and that every human
person
touches other people's lives in in all
sorts of ways also you might be lucky
enough to produce the uh the
scientific genius who's going to
get us out of this mess so i say go for
it maddie britt thanks
kathleen stock has faced harassment and
bullying for saying gender is not more
important than biological sex
particularly she said when it comes to
law and policy
is free speech under threat on our
campuses and if so what should be done
i'm joined now by matthew goodwin from
the university of kent and rob ford from
the university of manchester
thanks for joining us both
to start is that something kathleen
stock should have said matt let's come
to you first
yes i think she should be able to
express uh her views based on her
research i think uh ultimately
uh one of the reasons why our
universities are world-leading
universities is because of the fact that
we have academics with different views
who can come together and exchange those
views robustly and i also think given
the wider polarization that we are
experiencing in western democracies it's
more important i think today than ever
to ensure that our students are being
exposed to the very real views and
values that they're going to experience
when they leave university out there in
the real world so i think kathleen has
every right to express her view on
campus
rob
yeah uh same same view basically
i mean i i
do not think any academics should be
prevented from saying things that are
perfectly legal within the framework of
law that we have i think there are cases
that are more difficult where one has to
balance
academic free expression with for
example equalities legislation prevent
legislation and so on but the case that
you gave is is not one of those so it's
straightforward she should be able to
say it she shouldn't be facing
intimidation for wanting to say it and
the
notion that this is something that
should not be said is in a liberal one
and wrong
and do you think sussex union has had
the right response here we know that
there is a push uh uh by the union to
ultimately call for a full investigation
into transphobia
uh i mean we've got to separate out the
response of the university and the union
because it was very different things
i mean the university's response was to
put its vice chancellor up on the today
program to defend kathleen stocks i
believe the word he used was untrammeled
rights free speech
that strikes me as the right response to
what was a campaign an anonymous
campaign of intimidation on campus he
was standing up for his employee and
their rights
the union's response was rather
disappointing
i think it would have been nice for a
union which is supposed to be about
defending the rights of employees to
have made clearer uh and stronger
statement of defense they did however
say that intimidation is wrong
and they did also raise the point which
hasn't featured much incidentally a
discussion of this incident
that
the details personal details of local
union members at sussex who had raised
these objections were themselves posted
on the internet by various individuals
thereby encouraging further campaigns of
intimidation and frankly i think the
union is right to raise the fact that
that is also not a legitimate way to
conduct this debate
matthew what do you think are we seeing
a wider issue when it comes to academics
and um
wariness now about speaking out on
certain issues
i think we are i think in some way
kathleen was um
quite lucky in having a supportive vice
chancellor at least a vice chancellor
who was willing to
to go out there and make make the case
in defense of academic freedom that has
not been the case at other institutions
i
would note that the spectator among
others has pointed to the legacy of
stephen tupe at cambridge who would be a
prime example of a vice chancellor who
at least in my view fundamentally failed
to
um protect and promote academic freedom
and we've had a number of other cases
in the uk um where vice chancellors have
not proactively
um stepped into uh these debates when
they could have actually
done so and and could have could have
dampened them down i'm thinking about
the treatment in particular of neil thin
at the university of uh edinburgh uh who
uh was was sort of hauled through a very
long and messy and public disciplinary
process underlining the key point in
these cases which is that um the
process is the punishment for academics
so your reputation is essentially
shredded um while the university
uh sort of uh bows to to these mobs um i
think uh david runsman at cambridge made
this point very well yesterday in in the
you know even talking politics a sort of
another podcast feels unable to go near
issues uh such as uh gender and uh
trans issues because of the fear of the
consequences so we're not even talking
about a small minority uh
pointing to this issue anymore we're
talking about you know uh some of the
most prominent academics in the country
uh both on the left and the right who i
think are saying you know against the
backdrop of the kathleen stock case it's
no longer credible to say that we do not
have an issue
with academic freedom in the united
kingdom and i think
that is a very depressing place to be
and it reminds us that we need to do
something about it uh if we're going to
be able to move forward
do you agree with that rob that we now
do have a widespread issue when it comes
to freedom of speech on campuses
i think i would object to the word
widespread um i mean i agree with much
of what matthew says uh i think that we
are seeing a number of actors in the
debate over the over gender transgender
gender critical who are behaving in a
way that's deeply illiberal
i think there are examples of university
administrations
failing to provide a sufficiently robust
offence to their members in that area
but i think what
all of that omits is that universities
have more than one set of
responsibilities that they have to speak
to
they do also have to respect equality's
legislation now matthew mentions the
process is the punishment well yes and
that is a problem and sometimes
processes are far too long but to take
another case that has recently happened
this year which isn't on the gender
issue but on the issue of views about
israel
david miller at the university of
bristol lost his job he faced a very
long process it is still to this day not
clear on what grounds he was dismissed
now i would emphasize that in my view
david miller's views were fundamentally
unacceptable because they involved
threatening
disclosing the details of and
threatening and stigmatizing and
stereotyping individual name students at
his campus
but the university has to sort out
the different and conflicting
responsibilities it faces when you have
a situation on the one hand of
protecting the rights of academics to
speak freely and on the other hand
respecting
equality's legislation
with regards to protected
characteristics which would include
gender which would include ethnicity
which would include trance status
that is not necessarily a simple or easy
matter to sort out that does sometimes
require lengthy procedures which may
indeed include a need to remain silent
within a polarized public sphere in
order not to prejudice the case as it
goes through
so while i agree there clearly are
issues with illiberalism on some issues
and and
that illiberalism stretches well beyond
the university campus
it is also the case
that to think of this as an issue
solely in terms of free speech
is to miss the most important source of
tension and conflict within this issue
matthew
well i mean just to go back to your
question i mean i think the
the evidence
on
um
the problem that we have with academic
freedom today just before we go into
specific cases
is pretty overwhelming uh about two or
three years ago when a few colleagues
and i
started to race this issue and started
to form a working group on this issue
the i think it's fair to say
there was a very loud view you might
even say dominant view that this was
being exaggerated that this was being
um
uh perhaps used for political purposes
that essentially didn't really
exist as an issue and we saw a number of
prominent academics essentially
make make that case there was a strong
rebuttal to
some of the arguments that were made
through
various policy reports among a large
number of academics suggesting that this
was
um
being exaggerated or that we couldn't
possibly make um
conclusions uh about threats of academic
freedom based on
what those reports were showing i think
fast forward to today katie and we now
have so much evidence so much research
um
that i'm glad to see now today actually
against the backdrop of kathleen's case
that everybody now agrees uh with the
exception of one or two radicals who
continue to argue that this is being
made up
individuals such as jonathan porters and
others
i think there's a broad consensus on the
left and the right that we have an issue
and recent studies at king's even the
ucu zone survey
shows that one in three academics are
now self-censoring their views on campus
because they fear negative consequences
um they fear what will happen if they do
in in uh air their their real views
which david runserman i think expressed
very eloquently yesterday on
politics live so we do have an issue and
i would also add that as the
government's higher education and
academic freedom bills passing through
parliament which i know will come on to
discuss
i was quite struck by
the testimony from the chief executive
of the office for students who
also
agreed that
what she was seeing coming through
her office on a regular basis pointed
clearly to the need uh for us to take uh
some action on these issues so i i'm i'm
less of the view i i don't share rob's
um
uh
uh uh about um
uh about the equality's legislation i
think on some of these cases you think
that universities should ignore
equality's legislation no i didn't no i
didn't say that at all that was what i
was saying they have a responsibility so
i just it's important i can finish if i
just finish the point just if i can
finish the point there are there are
cases such as um kathleen stock's cases
uh neil thins uh case noah carl's
case i think in some respects how jordan
peterson was treated
at cambridge um among others where
actually i think vice chancellors
senior members of university actually
have a moral obligation
to
make the symbolic and substantive point
that academic freedom is the primary
goal within
higher education and they can do that in
some cases independently of particular
cases i was quite quite struck by adam
tickle's
response at sussex you know and i
thought it was a very good response
unfortunately he's now stepping down as
vice chancellor and we don't know what
the new vice chancellor is going to say
about this case
but i do think we have a moral
obligation as academics and as leaders
of universities to make the case that
actually the principle the fundamental
principle of academic freedom is one
that we should protect and promote and
the reason the government has not has
decided to take action in this area is
because it's concluded
and i think rightly that universities
have become so ideologically skewed that
they can no longer be relied upon to
promote
that academic freedom
and i think that's a fundamental problem
and just finally um i wanted to ask you
both about really who carries
responsibility when it comes to tackling
some of the problems that you both agree
there is a problem there's obviously a
disagreement as to the exact scale uh
response and um perhaps a start with you
matthew and then bringing rob for the
final word
you mentioned the government's um you
know free speech bill was doing there
and i just wondered do you think this is
something which is the government can
fix or ultimately is it are there limits
to what the government can really say on
this
so i think this is
um
it's a fascinating case it's a
fascinating case for global reasons as
well the uk is essentially becoming one
of the first
countries to to take such positive
action as in
proactive action on academic freedom the
canadians are watching us very closely
politicians in quebec and france are
watching this legislation very closely
um my view used to be i i think i'm
writing saying similar to robs but i'll
let him speak for himself i used to feel
incredibly uncomfortable about the idea
of government intervening in the higher
education space and
so you know i i've not come at this from
the view that this was my my starting
position but as i've gone through the
last decade in in higher education and
especially the five years since the vote
for brexit
and seeing the treatment of gender
critical scholars
friends in history
psychology even mathematics who have
been
bullied harassed intimidated
in some cases sacked or
disinvited
um i've come to the conclusion that our
universities are so ideologically skewed
have become um monocultures in some
cases that they are unable to be relied
upon to protect and promote academic
freedom and we have lots of research
that shows this when you have very
homogenous institutions they tend to
become more radical over time cass
unseen and others have shown this and i
think unfortunately that is what's
happened in our universities and this
relates also to issues around china as
well which i know that the spectator has
covered uh as well in some detail so so
my sort of reluctant conclusion
and reason for supporting the bill
is that i think we need culture change
within our universities
and the higher education academic
freedom bill by appointing an external
director of academic freedom who will
essentially provide oversight of issues
around academic freedom take the
kathleen stock case let's imagine for a
second the vc wasn't supportive of
kathleen let's imagine for a second that
the ucu as it as it as it was in this
case was not supportive
of kathleen stop where can she go apart
from walk onto campus and be bullied and
harass now she could bring a private
case she could perhaps
you know contact lawyers for herself and
so forth
but it becomes that much harder so so
the expectation the hope with this
legislation
is that it will begin to produce culture
changing universities because nothing
drives culture changing universities
more
than having things like league tables on
academic freedom uh and the and the
prospect of having negative publicity
for violating academic freedom as sussex
i'm sure would confirm to us uh this
week and that is the goal here it's not
to have a totalitarian authoritarian
kind of imposition in higher education
as some of our critics have tried to
make out the goal is a simple one which
is to provide an external entity that
academics who are being prosecute being
persecuted for their views and beliefs
can turn to uh to to to secure further
support and to have that uh organization
try and bring about wider culture change
rob do you
think the bill is a good idea
um largely no and not because i disagree
with the idea that you know
there are issues here
that need
greater attention as i think has become
clear from the conversation we both
agree that particularly in some of the
most contentious areas right now that's
true i just think that if the problem
is a cultural one and i actually agree
that it is a cultural one um and it
stretches beyond campus
that you can't just wave a magic wand
with legislation written on it and you
can't just wave a magic wand with
regulator on it and expect that to solve
the problem and i'll give a few reasons
why i think that's the case first of all
the example that matthew gives is not
one that is actually excellent to my
knowledge in any individual case i don't
know of any university academic in
britain
who has
lost their job due to lawful speech
there have been cases that have been
where they have faced harassment and
bullying and so forth
it is not clear to me
what the external regulator would
actually be able to do to change that
situation now that in itself is of
course very sad but it then raises the
question well what's the external
regulator for even in the david miller
case
and miller has lost his job and we still
don't know why
um
[Music]
the university was clear in its
statement that he has not lost his job
because of lawfully expressing his views
it emphasized that his views were an
awful expression of free speech if this
regulator was about regulating the
lawful expression of free speech they're
not going to have a lot to do because
most of the cases that cause trouble
are not about that they're about
universities other duties they're about
their safeguarding duties they're about
their equalities legislation duties
coming into conflict in particular cases
with
the
statements
and perceived reactions to those
statements from people on campus and so
i i don't think it will work for that
reason number one number two and this i
think is even more important there's a
jurisdictional problem here if you
actually look closely at many of the
people who protest in many of these
cases i'll give you another example the
jermaine greer case which incidentally
in the research that matt matt cited it
was treated as a case of cancellation
even though the event went ahead as
confirmed by the person who organized it
it took a while to get them to correct
the record on that
in the jermaine greer case the people
who organized the protest were not from
the university they were reported in the
daily mail as having been students of
the university even though the leader of
the protest confirmed he was not a
university student and had never been a
university student and neither were any
other people involved in the protest
we do have a broader problem here with
rather liberal extreme groups who are
willing to engage in intimidation and
disruption and i think that that is a
disgrace in the liberal society that
that is not the way that you go about
making your case however that problem
very often
does not fall within the jurisdiction of
universities universities cannot
sanction people who are not students or
staff on their campus it is difficult
for them to keep people off their campus
and a third problem i'd like to raise is
the problem of perverse incentives let's
say we have this external regulator and
the external regulator says any
university
that puts an event which is then
cancelled due to intimidation will face
sanction
the way many university administrations
which are institutionally risk-averse
will respond to that is to say any event
where there is a risk of cancellation
will just stop it from happening in the
first place if it's never announced if
it's never on the public record then
it's never cancelled
is that a victory for free speech
i would argue no i would argue the
situation where jermaine greer gets to
speak at cardiff university even despite
the protests is the victory for free
speech probably more people attended it
because of the publicity around the
protests and so forth the situation
where the vice chance of cardiff says oh
i don't want the regulator getting
involved in this this seems a bit like a
dodgy issue where we're going to have
trouble and media attention let's just
not put it on
that's not a victory for free speech
that's the opposite
and my concern with this legislation is
there's a failure to think through some
of the perverse incentives that it risks
creating
thanks rob and thanks matt
and finally who are vladimir putin's
mistresses and why is he so desperate to
hide his private life
in a piece for the spectator website
this week owen matthew says the recently
leaked pandora papers perhaps give us a
reason to explain who joins me now
oh and you start your piece by talking
about an 18 year old's instagram feed
can you tell us about it
yes uh this young lady who was born in
la zavierta vladimir krivanov
appears to be
or at least has been alleged last year
by a russian website which is
subsequently shut down nobody's
surprised that
this young lady is putin's love child
and the allegation was repeated again by
alexander alexey navalny
in his sensational video which has had
more than 100 million youtube views
about corruption in the putin's putin's
inner circle
and uh the shocking thing while there's
two shocking things one if you uh look
at the screen grabs of uh louisa
roosevelt she calls herself um
of
before she took off any kind of
recognizable images of herself she is
really the spitting image of vladimir
putin and she really is an absolute chip
off the old block
but the interesting thing is not really
putin's personal morality uh i don't
think anyone in this day and age is
particularly shocked by the fact that he
might have a rich and powerful man might
have a love child but uh the fact that
he uh she and her and her mother have
apparently again according to navainly
uh been in receipt of gigantic swathes
of state money and that appears to have
been confirmed last week with the
pandora papers uh which show a paper
trail leading to a very swanky apartment
in monaco just overlooking the harbour
which appears to belong to
louisa roosevelt
to her mother
svetlana krivanovic
who
was putin's mistress from the mid 90s
until
the mid 2000s apparently according to
the russian website
so we have a love child potentially and
a corruption row is there an outpouring
of outrage in russia over this among the
public well i i guess that was really
the main point of the story is actually
no
and there's two reasons for that one of
them is that putin's personal life is an
absolute taboo in fact weirdly enough
actually his love life is much more
taboo than his financial life i mean
obviously the kremlin is not very
delighted about the revelations of
various uh russian websites and
in particular about putin's finances
but it's been really clear right from
the beginning of putin's uh reign that
he absolutely will come down like a ton
of bricks on any website that reports
anything about his personal life
and uh that i think is one reason is
that it's not reported it's an absolute
taboo uh it's almost like sort of lay's
majesty in in thailand you can't say
anything bad about the king um the um
and the other reason i think is sort of
more of a cultural one actually is uh
russians are not surprised they're not
shocked
putin's behaved as
they expect their leaders to behave they
don't really care um either they don't
believe in navain many russians believe
that
and people like him
opposition leaders and freelance
investigators and journalists are kind
of somehow in the pay
of
foreign powers who are sort of
blackening the name of their beloved
putin
or if they do believe it they don't
really care
and you mentioned that there appears to
be a habit and it's very striking from
reading your piece of anyone who goes
near putin's private life as a
publication quite quickly has their
career come to an abrupt end
what do we know about putin's private
life um we're talking about uh one
instance in terms of this um supposed
love child her mother and the wealth
are there more mistresses are the
legitimate children and what is out
there
well there are uh he does have two
legitimate children although so intense
is his uh
uh secretiveness about his private life
which is of course you know completely
fair enough if it weren't for the fact
that they were also receiving hundreds
of millions of stolen stolen dollars uh
so so obsessively secretive is he that
is putin has actually never publicly
acknowledged his two legitimate children
by his uh ex-wife lyd mueller um and
despite the fact that they uh their
sort of semi-public figures their
identities are very well known uh their
husbands surprise surprise actually uh
have also received lucrative state
contracts and head up state companies
and so on but the um uh
the the the other famous mistress is
alina caballova who was
alleged to have been putin's mistress uh
in the late 2000s and um
there was allegations that she had a
love child that much less well
substantiated than the one than the
report on the
on
the crib
child but
was uh again reporting of their
relationship uh was absolutely taboo but
um and we also know nothing about kabaya
vs finances but we do know that she
actually has uh uh became a member of
parliament and uh for the united russia
party putin's official party and she
later uh now heads a major that's a
kremlin-owned media group
so um all these things uh um certainly
khabib was a much more open secret than
that story broke last november that that
nobody really knew but khabibo was
uh you know a public figure and uh putin
apparently didn't really have any any
compunction about promoting her publicly
although of course never officially
acknowledging that she had any kind of
romantic relationship with him in fact
denouncing journalists who sort of stuck
their snotty noses quote unquote uh into
his business
and we talked a bit about how little
impact really these stories about his
private life or perhaps partly because
there's lack of stories about his
private life have on putin's standing i
just wanted to own more generally what
is uh you know their current feeling
towards putin in russia um we're hearing
a lot here about nordstrom 2 how that
could strengthen his position
um but what is the mood
well he's uh
public opinion is predicated really on
on on one baseline and that is
on the government's ability to pay its
bills um of course the crash in world
oil prices since 2014 has
been a major uh headache for the kremlin
uh in 2014 obviously as we well remember
uh putin compensated for that and um
pushed his own personal approval ratings
into the stratosphere by invading a
small helpless country i mean that's uh
that has been done several times in
history um a short victorious war does
wonders for your popularity and uh ever
since uh that time into intervening uh
um seven years there's actually been um
you know everyone's been asking at what
point will the crimea effect wear off um
putin's party did take apparently quite
a kicking in the polls in uh uh last
month um although they've rectified that
by massaging the figures according to
election observers
and uh uh
putin's uh to answer your question
putin's ratings
are less than they were
post-crimea but they're still you know
very enviable and they're still in the
in the high 60s but the really important
thing is that actually fairly
meaningless statistic like because uh
you can ask people whether they support
putin because and
many russians will say yes because
there's actually no real alternative to
putin so that's really the the the big
the big question um the uh
the putin's political stock has been
held up by this
very heady mixture of patriotism
of um
this image of himself that he projects
as a national savior
and paradoxically actually all the
sanctions that have been brought in
after the crimea invasion so we've had
seven years of sanctions um cutting off
russian companies from international
markets to all kinds of economic
sanctions that the americans and the
europeans thought would punish putin
would damage his reputation exactly the
opposite
it's precisely the sanctions have worked
but in the absolutely 180 degree
converse way to that which they were
intended because what they did is they
created putin as a sort of uh not
exactly a martyr but a defender of the
motherland against foreigners that are
trying to attack us
so actually uh
strangely enough despite the fact that
they have been very low oil prices
obviously they're coming back up again
which is good news quids in rubles in
for putin and his team but um he's
actually uh his his position remains
actually very very strong
thanks to his control of the media and
his very rigorous
in a message discipline um
casting himself as being sort of almost
above everyday politics so all of the
flack from day-to-day discontent is
caught by the party united russia but
putin has sort of elevated himself into
a sort of position of a kind of modern
tsar
owen thank you for joining spectator tv
that's it for this week if you enjoyed
this episode don't forget to subscribe
to the spectators youtube channel so you
never miss an episode just click the
subscribe button at the bottom of this
video and tap the bell icon
thanks for watching and do join us again
next week
[Music]
you